hello and welcome to
section 5 features
so we now finish talking about
what a predictor is and how one
evaluates predictors and we can start to
move on by talking about how to
construct
predictors and the first step in the
process
is taking the data in its raw
form and embedding it
into vectors and i'm going to establish
a little bit more with a little bit more
formality right now exactly how
we do that and talk about a variety of
different ways in which we embed
data in vector space so that we can
use mathematical techniques to construct
predictors we have raw data pairs
which we will denote by u and v where u
is in some script u which is the set of
possible u's
and v is in some script with v the set
of possible v's
and here script u is the set of all
possible
input values and script v is the set of
all possible output values
and ideally our predictor is going to
take
an element of script u and return for us
an element of script v
the elements of u are called records
and typically they're a list of
attributes
of the data um these attributes these
which will index the uis are called
fields or components of the data and
notice here the i here is a subscript on
you
when we use a superscript that means the
ice
record when we use a subscript that
means the ice field
of a record and each of these fields has
a
type it might be a real number it might
be a boolean
it could be one of several different
types it could be a piece of text
could be audio it could be an image it
could be a
parse tree an output of a compiler
there are also certain generic types
that we talk about categorical
in ordinal types and i will tell you
what those are
shortly um
so for example you might have a um
the set u be a set of houses
and uh
and then a record would record the
properties
of um a house
so it might give us its address a
photo of the house perhaps some photos
of inside the house
a description which is a piece of text
a categorization of it as either
a house or an apartment the size of a
lot
the number of bedrooms and so on the
list goes on
um our goal
with all of these things is that we're
given all of this data and we're trying
to predict
say the price how much did the house
sell for
should the house sell for and notice
that each of these
fields of the description of a house
has a type so address
well that might be text or we might be a
little bit more
uh precise about what an address is
it might be a have a street number and a
street name and a
city and a county
we might have gps coordinates for the
location of the house
the description is is text but even
there we might
be able to be a little bit more refined
about that we might have description of
various
parts of the house we might have
standard forms for the description of
the house
and so how we take this data and
embed it in vector space is going to
affect a lot our ability to make useful
predictions using it
so abstractly the uh
the functions that we use to do this
embedding
are called the feature maps and we have
two of them
one of them takes u and embeds it in
d-dimensional vector space and gives us
x one of them the other one takes
v and embeds that in m-dimensional
vector space
and gives us y and learning algorithms
are applied to x
y pairs which are just vectors
and the functions are called phi and psi
so
phi takes a u and gives us an x and psi
takes a v
and gives us a y and these are the
feature maps
they transform data records
into vectors
usually feature maps work on the
separate fields so we'll have a feature
map that maps the
photograph into a vector space we have a
feeder feature map that maps the address
into a vector space and so we've really
got a different
feature map for each of the different
fields
of a particular record and
um and then we'll construct one
feature map which takes
uh the entire record and
maps that into a vector space and the
way it does it is by mapping each of the
fields
of the record into each of their
component vector spaces and then
joining up all the vectors into one long
vector
so phi subscript i is an embedding
it's if it's uh it's a map which takes
field i
into a vector and the overall function
phi
is the feature map that combines all
these embeddings
and takes a record into a vector
the the reason we do this is so that we
can put all the different field types
on an equal footing they're all vectors
and some some of these embeddings are
very very simple so
if the raw data is actually just a real
number
such as the uh the lot size of the house
then we might just embed it by using the
identity map we'll just embed
it according to x it's equal to u um
uh sometimes uh uh
a field may be boolean um
and so for example uh
uh it might be uh uh
for a house it might be has a pool and
the answer could be yes or no
and uh in which case we would map that
to
a real number in a vector space
by saying 1 if the answer is yes and
minus 1 if the answer is no
or we might map it according to 1 if yes
and 0 if no
uh color um we might map to
uh three numbers uh the amount of red
the amount of green
uh the amount of blue and uh that's a
very typical encoding for color
which we use a lot for images but it's
by no means the only one
and uh there are quite a few different
standard color encodings
um there are also much more
sophisticated encodings which we will
have a
chance to talk about later
so one is this one has a text document
and one wants to
embed that as a vector then there's a
map
called the tfidf map that stands for
term
frequency inverse document frequency
and we'll see exactly what that is and
why it's useful for
learning properties of text building
predictors
for text another one for text is called
word to back we'll see that in just a
second
that maps individual words into vectors
rather than mapping hold
documents into vectors um
another one is that instead of thinking
about an image as a collection of pixels
we use a particular feature map
to map the image into vectors
and these are pre-trained neural
networks
and we will see uh an example of this
for shortly
one of the things we want out of an
embedding is that it should be
faithful and what that means is that it
should somehow preserve
similarity so if
you and utilde are two
different records but somehow they're
similar they correspond to two similar
houses
then when we embed them we get a phi of
u and we get a phi
of utilda and those two vectors
should be close to each other in the
vector space
and conversely if phi of u is not near
5u tilde well then u and utilda should
be
dissimilar houses and
so the the geometry and the
distances within our vector space should
somehow correspond
to our intuitive notions
of similarity for our
underlying raw data
and this particular notion of similarity
well it depends on the
application that we have in mind it
depends on the field type that we're
looking at for houses we have some idea
of what that means they should be
similar size
they should be similar quality of
construction
they should be similar types of houses
similar numbers of bedrooms we have some
idea of what that
means and for many other things it won't
be so obvious as to
what it means in any numerical sense but
it might be obvious
in an intuitive sense we know that for
example two images that are both images
of cats
are similar to each other but they're
distinct from
an image of a dog and that's something
that we're going to have
trouble quantifying we'll see there are
texts there are ways
of um embedding in uh
in such a way as to have a faithful
representation of such things and we
will get to those
so there are lots of interesting
examples one might think about where
it's not so obvious
how to construct a faithful embedding we
can think about names of people
professions companies
countries languages zip codes
cities songs movies
and we're going to see several of these
and examples and we'll also see some
generic
general techniques for constructing
embeddings
here's one suppose you have uh location
data
you have the position of something
on the world um so you might
describe that by two numbers the
latitude and longitude
that would give us a two-dimensional
vector in r2
or you might say really this should be
embedded in r3
we think about the the world as a
globe and the globe is has a natural
embedding
in three-dimensional space and so
we can embed our position
in on the surface of the globe as a
position on the sphere in our sv
maybe that makes more sense if your data
points are spread over
the planet
here's another example the day of the
week
um so we have monday tuesday wednesday
thursday friday saturday sunday we could
just enable
label them one through seven and that
would be a an embedding
we should embed them uh by the day of
the week
into a one-dimensional vector space
also on this slide we see a
two-dimensional vector space
this is interesting this is useful
because for many types of data
the similarity between days
is that a day is similar to the day
before and a day after
and um if we were to embed monday as one
and tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday sunday is seven
then one and seven would be quite far
apart and so monday and sunday would be
quite
far apart if we embed them like this
so here we've embedded them as seven
points in our r2
well then we can see that the distance
between monday and tuesday
and the distance between monday and
sunday those two distances
are the same and indeed the distance
between any two
consecutive days is uh
is the same and so this is an embedding
that more faithfully captures that idea
and we can do that for lots of different
notions of time we can do that for
um months of the year which you might
embed
as 12 points we can do that for hours
of the day which we might embed around
the circle
that's 12 points around the circle
now here's a more sophisticated example
this
is a word to beg
and that's a mapping on words so you
give
the here the field type is a word a word
in the english language
and um
words to vec for each word in the
english language
you map it will map it to a vector
and that vector is a 300 dimensional
vector
um and so where to beg actually will
work on words and short
phrases it doesn't just include
dictionary words but it also includes
names of people
and names of places and many other
things and it's developed from a data
set which comes from google news
which contains 100 billion words and so
this is not
a hand constructed embedding or hand
constructed feature map this is an
automatically
constructed embedding
and we will say more about how that is
done later in the class
the principal idea here is that words
that frequently appear
near each other should get
nearby vectors and um ah
so we might look at that now
of course it's hard to look at the
specific vectors that correspond to
where to vect because
um they're 300 dimensional so we can't
plot them
but of course we can use them for all
sorts of predictor construction
however here we can we can just plot
some of their components so here are two
of their components x1 and x2
of a bunch of different words let's zoom
in a bit here
and so you can see even when you look at
a two-dimensional projection
of this 300 dimensional vector space
you can see that words that sort of mean
similar things are kind of close
together
uh let's look here we've got uh
optimistic
let's see if i can make that a bit
smaller
we've got optimistic proud enthusiastic
happy satisfied eager
interested amazed these are all kind of
next to each other down here
uh we've also got uh melancholy
sorrow hostile bitter
awkward guilty anguished hopeless
vengeful lonely what kind of negative
words
sitting at the top there
we've got some others we've got some uh
irritated exasperated angry
embarrassed frustrated scared
all of these kind of similar words over
there
and so here are these are just a
selection of words these are the
emotion words of course there are uh
three million words in the database um
and this is just a two-dimensional
projection but nonetheless one can see
the
what it does in terms of grouping there
are also some interesting properties
of word to vec some nice
other types of faithfulness of the data
that comes out
for example if i take the vector
for king and subtract
the vector for man
and then i add the vector for woman
then the closest vector that i get
to the result is the vector for queen
similarly if i take
rome and subtract italy and add france
then the closest vector i get is paris
and so these kinds of things are
somewhat surprising
properties of the embedding that
are quite magical but illustrate the
point that
somehow the embedding is capturing the
structure
of the relationship between words
um which is uh what's going to enable it
to be useful when we actually use it for
learning
let's turn now to a sophisticated method
of embedding image data and
uh this is uh called
vgg16 so
imagenet is an open
database of images it contains about
14 million labeled images
in about a thousand different classes
and they range over all sorts of
different things they include many
images of animals
of vehicles of
everyday objects
shoes that's
a very broad collection of images
but they've all been labeled and so
we know exactly what is in each of those
images
so vgg16 is an embedding
which maps images um
to a vector in rd
and here d is 4096.
so we get a 4096 long vector
and the images that we start with are
all cropped down to 224 by 224 pixels
their color so they have rgb components
and that is uh
some uh 150 160 odd thousand
components 160 odd uh
components of each image and we have
three numbers per pixel
and so we're going from what we might
think of as a as a
vector in 160 000 dimensions and we're
mapping it down to a vector in
40 96 dimensions
and vgg16 it's a neural network and it
was originally developed to
classify the images and so it learned
from the imagenet database
the uh a way of
mapping images to labels but it's also
been repurposed as a general
method of constructing a feature
map it's a general method of embedding
images in vector space
now this particular neural network has
16 layers
and its input is an image and its output
is the
vector in r4096
let's look at what it looks like
so here are six different
uh images they're each 224 by 224
image one is simply the ubuntu mug
2 and 3 are some guy
image 4 is professor steven
boyd image 5 is a car it
happens to be a a mini traveler edition
from the 1960s
and the image 6 is a london bus
for those of you who haven't yet figured
out for my accent i
am english and
this particular car is actually
exactly the same type of car my family
drove about in when i was
10 years old and this is
exactly the kind of london bus that i
would have
ridden on back in those days although
the car that we had was
blue not green um
so let's take these images um
and embed them under the vgg16
map and for each one of them we're going
to get a 4096
long vector and what we've done here
is uh com looked at it looked at those
images in pairs
and for each pair of images computed the
distance
in terms of the euclidean norm between
the two corresponding embedded vectors
so let's look at this embedding the
matrix here
is a matrix of the pairwise distances
between the embedded vectors of each of
the images
so for example this number right here
is the 2 3 entry of the matrix
and so that's the distance between image
2 and image 3.
both of which are images of me and so we
expect them to be close
if this is a faithful embedding
if we compare that distance between with
the distance between image two
and image five well
then suddenly we're looking at the a
number of 109 compared to 63 which is
substantially different
and we can see that the two images of me
are rather close to each other
whereas image 2 is quite far from
an image of a mini and same
for the distance between an image of me
and
uh the image of the bus those are also
quite far apart
and the same is true for the other
images of me
image three to image five and image
three to image six are also quite far
apart
uh and if we compare steven to the
the bus and the car he's also
quite distinct from a bus and a car
however the distance between image 2 and
image 4
we're both people those are both head
shots we can see that those numbers are
quite a lot smaller
than the corresponding distances between
humans and people
if we compare image three and four
that's the other image of me
and steven they're also quite close
well there's one more interesting pair
that's comparing the vehicles
so that's this number right here that's
the distance between image five and
image six
so that's this distance right there and
we can see that the two vehicles are
considered much closer
at 86 than a vehicle in any person which
are all about a hundred
so this image this embedding is faithful
uh we can also look at the
um
the uh the images of the mug you can see
that the images of the mug
are all quite far
from all the other images in terms of
euclidean norm distance
and so we can say well this is a
reasonably faithful
embedding it's it's it's surprisingly
effective at figuring out
that three faces are kind of similar to
each other
two vehicles are kind of similar to each
other but faces are really
different from vehicles and mugs
are different from faces and mugs are
different from vehicles
notice here that we didn't give it data
that it had been developed for
we i picked these images from uh
some other source none of these images
are as far as i know on
image on imagenet and so
here we're repurposing uh
a trained set of features
and we're using effectively different
images
and that sort of idea where one takes
a model that has
been developed using a particular data
set and then uses it for a different
learning task is called transfer
learning
now we usually assume that an embedding
is standardized
that's not always the case but it is
very often the case
and certainly when we construct
embeddings by hand we go out of our way
to make sure they're standardized
what that means is that they're centered
around zero and they have an rms value
around one
and of course that means for a
particular data set
we take all of the records
u in a data set and uh
we look at the we take each of them and
embed them under
phi so we get a whole bunch of phi u's
which is a bunch of vectors
and that set of vectors should be
centered around zero
and that set of vectors should have an
rms value around one
um and so that means that roughly
the entries of five u range between plus
and minus 1 very roughly
and with standard embeddings that means
that if i've
embedded each of these features
phi 1 up to phi r here into
to have this property that they're all
centered around 0
and have rms value around 1 that means
they're all comparable
a large value of
x1 which is phi 1 of u1 and a large
value of x2
phi 2 of u2 will both be around 1 or 2
and a small value will both be around
minus 1 or minus two
um and it means that we can compare them
we don't need to worry about what units
the original data u1 and u2 was in
or what magnitude they naturally have
we've normalized
and we might measure the distance
between
two embedded vectors using the rms
and so we take the rms of the vector 5u
minus phi
of utilda that's a reasonable measure of
how close records you and you today are
that's again a consequence of the
faithfulness
of the embedding
and so the way we ensure
that all of our data has
this property that is centered at zero
and has
uh values that range between plus and
minus one you do what's called
standardization
it's also called z scoring um so suppose
we've got
real numbers in the the field type
and then we've got u1 through un which
are real numbers
uh then what we might do is we might
define u
bar to be
the
average of the uis
and stood u to be the standard deviation
of the use and then in order to
construct
uh a vector or in this case a scalar
x which is an embedding of u
which is normalized we do what's called
the
z-score transformation where we take
u subtract it from subtract from it
u bar
and then divide by the standard
deviation
and that ensures that first of all that
the average
of the x's is zero
and the standard deviation of the x's is
one
so these are very easy to interpret all
of a sudden
if i've got uh z scored features
and i look at x when i see an x which is
1.3
well that means that the corresponding u
is one point three standard deviations
above the mean
now another transformation we might do
be uh before
z-scoring is taking the log now this is
a very standard rule of thumb
if you've got a field u
which is a positive number but it ranges
over a very wide scale
then you embed it as phi of u is equal
to log
of u sometimes you'll use log of one
plus u if u is
allowed to be zero and then your
standardized
so for example if u is the
amount of traffic that a particular
website receives well then you've got a
bunch of different websites
and each one has a different amount of
traffic and there is a huge difference
between the amount of traffic that the
big websites like amazon and google
receive and then rather smaller websites
such as my own website receives
and these are many many orders of
magnitude different
and so uh with this kind of thing
it's much better to instead of trying to
uh
look at numbers over such a wide range
of scales to take the logs
and then we might conclude that well
a thousand and eleven hundred are very
similar
20 and 22 are also very similar
um but 20 and 120 are not similar
if we were to measure those in absolute
terms we might say well 20 and 120 are a
hundred apart
and a thousand and eleven hundred are a
and so we should consider them both
equally similar
and 20 and 22 are only two apart so
they're very similar
but actually if we look at it in a log
scale
we'll find that 20 and 22 and a thousand
and 1100
are both equally different or equally
similar
and 20 and 120 are much further apart
and because we're taking logs what we
end up measuring
is the relative difference between the
values rather than the absolute
difference between the values
another way to say it is that 22 is only
more than 20. 1100 is only 10
more than a thousand
and here's an example for house price
prediction
we want to predict uh the house selling
price v
we've got a record which in this case
just has two fields u1 and u2
u1 is the area in square feet
u2 is the number of bedrooms
we care about relative errors in price
so
we're much more we can say if two house
prices differ by
ten percent we will consider them as
similar
um and uh that allows us to consider
uh a million dollars and one point one
million dollars is just as similar
as a hundred thousand dollars and a
hundred and ten thousand dollars
um
and so we'll embed the price v as
using psi of v as log v and then we'll
standardize
we also standardize the records
u in particular we stand aside
standardize the fields u1
and u2 and we do that by subtracting the
corresponding means and dividing by the
standard deviations
and the reason we do this is easy to see
if we consider having two different
records so we suppose i have a record u
and a record u-tilde and then i'd like
to say well
how close are you in utila well let's
just write that down
well then u minus u tilde
the 2 norm squared
that's going to be equal to u 1 minus u
1 squared plus u 2
minus u tilde 2 squared
and so the first term in this
is the difference in the number of
bedrooms
of house you and house utilde
and the second is the difference in the
price
of house you and house utilita and both
of those quantities are squared and
added up
of course the trouble is is that even a
very small
change in price is going to swamp
a change in number of bedrooms and yet a
change in the number of bedrooms from
three to four
could be hugely significant much more so
than a change in the price from 200 000
to 250
000.
so standardizing puts these two
different fields
on equal footing within our embedded
vector space
so then we're going to predict why
y is log v the log of the price from the
standardized area
in the standardized number of bedrooms
we'll have a linear predictor
which will be y hat is theta 1 plus
theta 2
x 1 plus theta 2 times x 2
plus theta 3 times x 2. i'm sorry
and so in terms of the original data
we're going to
uh so how does this work we start off
with a
a bunch of data which we use in order to
determine theta 1
theta 2 and theta 3. and then we get
given a new
house that we've never seen before a new
record
and that gives us a u1 and a u2
a number of bedrooms and a square
footage
we take that number of bedrooms and
number of square footage and we
standardize them
to get an x one and next two
we then apply our predictor y hat is
theta one plus theta two x one
plus theta three x two to get a y hat
which is a prediction of the log of the
price
and so our predicted price is
constructed by inverting that embedding
y is log v by to using v hat is the
exponential of y
so v hat is going to be x of theta 1
plus theta 2 times u 1 minus mu 1 on
sigma 1
plus theta 3 times u 2
minus mu 2 and sigma 2.
and this is very interpretable
um so for example if here theta 2 is 0.7
what does that mean well it means that
every time u1 increases
by one standard deviation
that means the price of the house is
going to get multiplied
by the exponential
of 0.7 which is about 2
so every change
in
u1 which i think is area yeah
every change in area by one standard
deviation
doubles the house price
let's look at some more complicated
embeddings where we take an individual
field
and embed it as a vector
so we can embed a field into
a vector xs5 view and now
x here lives in rk that's the
dimension in which that particular field
is embedded and it's useful to have a k
which is more than one even when
the quantity that you're embedding the
raw data you is just a raw
it's just a real scalar we've already
seen that with the polynomial embedding
where phi of u is one u u squared up to
u to the d
and that's useful because it allows us
to use a linear predictor
to construct
a predictor which is a non-linear
function of u
even though the predictor is a linear
function of x
and there are other things you can do
you can similarly use other nonlinear
functions
you might embed it as 1 u minus
u plus it's worth drawing what these
functions are
so let me try and do that
so this is going to be u
and then
i'll plot the function use there
and i will also
plot the function
0 which just sits right there
and then u subscript minus is the
minimum of these two functions
which means
that there is u subscript minus
and u subscript plus is the maximum of
these two functions
and so that means that
this here
is u plus so i've got two functions
we think about u plus as being the
positive
part of u and
u minus as being the negative part of u
now what that means if i'm trying going
to construct
a linear predictor with these two
features
it means well let's write that down
uh let us
so i'm going to have a linear predictor
which is a function of these two
features
i'm going to have y hat
which is going to be theta 1 plus
theta 2 over u plus
plus theta 3
of u minus
and uh so this is a constant
this is a linear
function of u on the positive part
of when u is greater than zero and it's
a constant
when u is negative and this is a linear
function of u
for when u is negative and it's a
constant when u is positive
what that means is that my function
y hat
is a function of u i can plot it
and it will look something
like this it has a particular slope here
a particular slope here and a particular
intercept
there and those three quantities are
determined by theta one
theta two and theta three in particular
the intercept is theta one
the slope of this part of the line
is theta 2 and the slope of this part of
the line
is theta 3. and so i have a
piecewise
linear function
now it's also worth being aware that
when one talks about
piecewise linear functions often one
thinks about
that meaning a function where the
joint it is composed of linear segments
and
the joins between the linear segments
may be anywhere
and i may have any number of segments
here
we're choosing predictors which are
piecewise linear functions but they're
very specific
piecewise linear functions they only
have two
linear pieces and the join has to be
at the origin join has to be
somewhere
there
this particular quantity the
the origin in this case is called a not
for this piecewise linear function
that's a knot
and you might have more complicated
piecewise linear functions
which you could construct using a
different embedding
so for example if my embedding was
1 u plus
u minus and u
minus 1 plus
well then there'd be an additional not
out here at 1
when i'd be able to pick a different
slope
and then slope would be determined by
these additional parameters well i've
got four parameters theta one theta two
theta three and theta four
it's worth noticing also that the slope
of this line
will not just be the coefficient in
front of u
minus 1 plus but it will in fact be the
coefficient the sum
of the coefficient of u minus 1 plus and
the coefficient of u
plus
now then a particular type of data field
is called categorical
and what that means is it only takes a
finite number
of possible values in other words the
set
script u is a finite set and we've
called
the entries in that set alpha 1
up to alpha k those are called the
category labels
sometimes we'll use category labels 1
through k and we'll refer to category i
sometimes will be explicit about alpha 1
to alpha k and refer to category alpha i
depending on what works best at that
particular
notational point lots of things are
categorical variables
the most common is the boolean true or
false
there's only two possible values
we might be trying to identify fruit
in which case
we might have apple orange and banana
we might have a field which is the day
of the week
in which case there are seven possible
values monday through sunday
we might have zip codes that's 40
000 possible values roughly um
you could just say well embed that as a
real number
but then we'd ask the question well is
that faithful
and we might conclude well there's no
particular reason why
two zip codes that are numerically close
should be physically close
sometimes they are and sometimes they
are not
uh countries of course they're not
numerical at all and so
there are maybe about 180 or so
different countries that we might
list in just a bunch of different
categories
uh languages there are several thousand
different languages
um at least those which are spoken by a
large number of people
now there's a particular way of
embedding categoricals which is very
common and very useful
and that's called the one hot embedding
so let's just refer to our categories
now as
one through k so that script u
is has k positive it consists of the
numbers one two k
any the value of the field is either
going to be 1 or 2 or
up to k so the one hot embedding says
if you see
u is equal to i then embed that as e
subscript i remember what e subscript i
is so in
a vector space e 1 is just the vector
1 0 0
e 2 is just the vector 0
e 3 is the vector 0
0 one zero and so on
people call it the e i the eighth
canonical basis vector
in a vector space and so in a k
dimensional vector space there are
k different canonical basis vectors
and so we can embed the categories
one through k as the k different basis
vectors
in rk
so in particular we might embed apple as
one zero zero
orange as zero one zero and banana as
zero zero one
we might embed true as one zero and
false
as zero one and this is a different
embedding of the booleans into
r2 this time as opposed to the minus one
one embedding we saw earlier we might
embed
languages there's a bunch of different
canonical basis vectors
uh all the way up to
185 of them
um and if we uh
standardize these features well that
allows us to handle
unbalanced data because
when we standardize these features they
won't remain
at one zero zero zero one zero zero zero
one they will get
shifted by the mean
and scaled by the standard deviation
and in particular the mean and the
standard deviation of the data set
will be affected by the proportions of
the different categories that show up in
the data set
and that's a nice way of handling
unbalanced data sets
and we will see some of the problems
that show up with unbalanced data sets
later in the class
there's also another way of doing uh one
hot embedding which is called reduced
one hot embedding
and here the idea is is that instead of
it
mapping the categories 1 through k
to k dimensional space we map them to k
minus 1 dimensional space
where we do this is we choose one of the
categories say the last one
category k as the default value the
nominal value
and we embed that at the origin
all of the other categories 1 through k
minus 1
we embed as the first k minus 1
canonical basis vectors e 1 to e k minus
1 as before
if we do that for the booleans then we
would embed true
as 1 and false as 0 because here k
is two there's only two categories and
so r k minus one
is simply the real numbers and uh
so we're embedding booleans as one and
zero
and this is a very common embedding of
the booleans
there's another type of data a specific
type of categorical data and that's
categorical data that's ordered
now apple pear banana are very much not
ordered quantities there's no natural
order to put the fruit in
but very often you do have uh orderings
so for example when you uh uh
give something a rating on amazon and
uh you're either gonna give it one two
three four or five stars
and yes there's only five possible
categories that you can put it in
but those definitely have an order
such a scale where
there's uh an order to the categories
it is uh and it's used to indicate a
preference
is called a leicard scale l-i-k-e-r-t
um yeah so for example
uh the original leica scale was strongly
disagree
disagree neutral agree or strongly agree
you know leica was actually a person
it's not just a scale it measures how
much you like something
like was a psychologist
an american psychologist who lived in
michigan
he lived for most of the
20th century the
likert scale can be embedded into the
real numbers
with values minus two minus one zero one
or two and it's nice it's a faithful
embedding
in the sense that it preserves
the ordering of the different categories
it's also quite reasonable to treat the
lycra scale as a categorical
with one heart embedding into our five
um that way is perhaps a little less
faithful
but both ways are very common
you can do the same thing with other
categoricals as well for example the
number of bedrooms in a house
you could treat it as a real number
or you could treat it as an ordinal with
values between one and six
and both would be completely reasonable
so i want to talk right now about
feature engineering
this is the next stage after embedding
so in embedding we're starting with raw
data
and we are putting that data
into a vector space so that we can use
mathematics to develop machine learning
algorithms
the next stage is to think about feature
engineering
and in feature engineering the basic
idea is that we start with some features
and then we process or transform them to
make new
engineered features and
instead of just having a predictor which
is dependent
of on the original embedding
we have a predictor which is in bit
which is dependent on these new features
uh we can do this in lots of different
ways and we've seen some
ways already so one example of this
is where we used a polynomial embedding
of a real raw data
we embedded it as one u u squared u
cubed and so on
and you could either think about that as
an embedding or as
feature engineering where we've chosen
features in a particular way in the hope
that it will improve our predictor
in that case what it does is it allows
our linear predictors to become
polynomial predictors
now fundamentally the question you have
to ask yourself is
what feature engineering should you do
does it
improve the predictor um and there's an
answer to this question that
is worth repeating to yourself
throughout this class
and and that is is that the way you tell
whether one predictor is better than
another
is by validating the performance
so if you want to know whether these new
features
that you're producing using feature
engineering are helpful
are better than the original features
then
develop a predictor using the original
features
developer predictor using the new
in both cases validate the performance
against unseen data
if the performance with the new features
is better well then your feature
engineering is actually helpful
and if it wasn't then you don't need to
do that particular piece of feature
engineering and
look at something else the point is is
that
there is no answer to this question
there is
no answer to how one should embed a
particular type of data
for a particular type of problem the
answer comes about
through validation through measuring the
performance
against a data set in determining
whether the performance is better with
that sort of features
after the fact sometimes you can come up
with some
post hoc explanation for why
certain features were better you can say
things like well obviously
for numbers of bedrooms one should use
uh one hot embedding rather than uh
ordinal embedding into the reels but
there's no truth to
such post-hoc explanations
those are just justifications for
uh what happened with the outcome that
happened to turn out that way
the only test the only way of knowing
whether one
set of features is better than another
is to validate
there are several different types of
feature
transforms one
is to modify particular features that
you have
so you've got a feature x i and you
replace it with an
with a transformed feature of x i new
so you might standardize for example um
another thing you can do is you can say
well i've got one feature
and i'm going to take that one feature
and can create multiple features from it
that's the power as example we take
x i we replace it with x i x i squared
x i cubed and so on
another thing you can do is you can take
more than one
feature and combine them together to
create new features
so for example you can take two features
say x1 and x2 and create a new feature
which will be the product of x1 and x2
here's a feature that's very commonly
used this is the gamma
transform you take x and you replace it
with sine of x
multiplied by the absolute value of x to
the power of some constant gamma
and that produces curves that are shown
in this plot right here
if gamma is a half for example
it produces a curve that looks like that
that's a case where we might believe for
example that a feature has diminishing
importance as its magnitude grows and so
we might replace it um we might replace
x by the absolute value of x to the
power of a half
um again
that's a justification but it doesn't
necessarily mean
that if a feature has diminishing
importance then you should use the gamma
transform
it's something reasonable to try
particularly if you're using a linear
predictor
but the only way to know whether it's
better or not is to validate
another thing you can do is clip this is
also called saturation
or winds arising there's a nice little
formula for it here the new x is equal
to x
if x is between l and u or it's equal to
u when x is greater than u
or it's equal to l when x is less than l
and that saturized
saturates like this
and so values larger than in this case
than
one i just treat it as if they're one
values
less than minus one i just treat it as
if they're minus one
we might believe that for example our
data contains anomalies
very large data values
that are really a an artifact
of the way the data was measured and we
know that the physical quantity that's
being measured can never exceed values
of 1 or minus one in which case windsor
rising would be a reasonable thing to do
here's powers we've seen these already
this
we know that this is u u
squared
and u cubed
and here's one we've seen already as
well u plus and u minus
these are splitting x into
uh positive and negative parts
there's an additional one here which is
worth looking at
this is the saturation function sat of
x sat of x is the
minimum of 1 the maximum of x and minus
1.
we can plot that let's try and do that
the maximum of x and minus 1 well this
is the minus 1
function and this is the x function
so the maximum of x and minus 1
is
that function right there and then we
take
the minimum of that function and one and
the one function is right here
and so the minimum of those two
functions is
let me draw it
right here that's the sat function it's
the
windsorization it's another way of
expressing
the windsorization or the saturation
function that we saw
over here
another thing one can do is create new
features for multiple features
so we can model interactions among
features so for example
um you might create all products
x i x j or you might create
the maxima maximum of x i and x j
you can also create all the monomials of
degree 3 or less
x1 x2 x1 squared x1 x2
and so on and that would give us an
arbitrary polynomial of degree 3.
products can be thought about as a nice
way of modeling interactions
and so can maxima so for example suppose
x
i are boolean so and we've embedded them
to take values 0 or 1.
they might represent say patient
symptoms
then we create interaction features
which are the products
of x i x j and of course we only need to
consider the terms which i is less than
j
because x i x j is equal to x j x i
so there are going to be if we have d
original features we're going to add
d times d minus one divided by two
additional features
then if we do linear regression say when
d is 3 we're going to get
an expression which looks like theta 1 x
1 plus theta 2
x 2 plus theta 3 x 3 plus theta 1 2
x 1 x 2 plus theta 1 3 x 1 x 3
plus theta 2 3 x 2 x 3 those would be
that would be the form of a linear
predictor
with those new features
now these are very nicely interpretable
these coefficients because theta one is
the amount the prediction goes up when x
one is one
theta two is the amount of production
goes up when x three is one
and c two one three is the amount the
prediction goes up when both
x1 and x3 are one
in addition to c to one and theta three
you get this additional boost
in your prediction and so this is saying
that
when two symptoms both occur
then we believe our predicted
value of whatever it is we're predicting
should have an additional amount
added to it c to one three
another way to say is that if theta 1 3
is large then
if you've got both symptoms
simultaneously present
then we increase our estimate a lot
another thing one can do in future
engineering is
quantization we specify
bin boundaries b1 to bk and we partition
the real numbers into buckets the
interval
from b1 to b2 from b2 to b3 and so on
and then we replace
x by
the following we embed it as e one
through e k plus 1 where
the embedding returns e1 if x1 is less
than equal to b1
it returns e2 if x1 is in the next bin
between b1 and b2
and so on so x maps to e
i if x is in bin i
this is a one hot embedding of
the ordinal that results from figuring
out which
bin x is in
and you might say well why would you
ever do that
and the answer to that kind of question
is always the same
is that this is the kind of thing you
try
and see whether it works
the only way to know whether or not it's
better
is to try it and validate sometimes you
may believe
that this the case where x is in these
different bins
those are really different situations
and so the predictor should treat them
differently
and introducing these kinds of features
is one way to
develop a predictor that treats
these different cases differently that
would depend on
what type of predictor you're using and
uh so it's a it's an intuitive
motivation rather than a
rigorous motivation ultimately
one validates to determine whether or
not such a prediction such a
piece of feature engineering is a good
idea or not
now you can do these many times you
don't have to do
embedding and then one round of feature
engineering you can
compose them with each other you start
by embedding the original record u
into a feature vector which we'll call
x0
and then you transform x0 using a
feature engineering transform to get x1
that might be standardized
and then you repeat again you may do a
polynomial embedding or you might do
binning or you might do windsorization
then you repeat this m times and you've
got a composition of different feature
maps
and that gives you the final embedding
this is called the feature engineering
pipeline
now there's one more topic that i want
to mention
in this section and that's automatic
feature generation
so the features that we've seen so far
are
generally done by hand using experience
and that's hard to do essentially
it's done when one's trying these kinds
of things there are things that one
knows
is are generally a good idea
standardization
logarithms one hot embeddings
and there are things that one has
experience of
in certain domains certain embeddings
work well in certain domains
products for symptoms for example is a
very good thing to do
um and then there is
the rest of it which is largely trial
and error
one can try a bunch of different feature
engineering tricks
and hope that they improve your
validation results
and because it's trial and error it
would be very nice to be able to develop
feature
mappings automatically directly from the
data
and this is certainly possible we've
already seen two examples one is word to
vec
where words were mapped to vectors
another is vgg16 where images were
mapped to vectors
and those were learned and they would do
so they were developed automatically
from very large data sets
and those are very important methods
they have made a huge
difference to our ability to do
effective machine learning
and we will see later those methods in
some detail and we'll talk about
some specific methods for constructing
these things pca is an example that
stands for principle component analysis
neural networks is another example
so to summarize all features are mapped
to vectors
that's embedding it's the feature map
we subsequently process those vectors
in our predictor we
may do extensive feature engineering to
construct more and more complex ways
of mapping features to vectors
only validation can choose between
different candidate
feature maps
and we're going to see later how feature
mappings can be derived from data
as opposed to by hand